>>Jennifer: Okay. How many activities
did you find out that she has?
>>Ambar: Because of the
professional growth partners,
it makes me see things
in a different light.
By sharing our practices and
providing feedback to one another,
every educator in our
building has the capacity
to become the best educator they can be.
>>So today, I notice a lot of
students working independently.
I have some questions.
If you notice here--
>>The vision of our school is
that all scholars can learn
as [inaudible] does not
determine your destination.
Every educator sees the responsibility
that they have to all students
when teachers learn and grow.
That benefits everyone in the building.
Our Peer Inter Visitation initiative is
a way to promote professional growth.
So we call each other
professional growth partners.
And we have six weeks to go into each
other's classroom to observe and learn.
>>Partner: Page 59.
>>Jennifer: I mean, initially,
when you get anybody
in your room, you get a little nervous.
But when you're getting
observed from your colleagues,
I think there's more of,
like, a comfort level.
And you learn best practices from
one another, so you see strategies
that you can then implement
in your classroom
that could work for your
students as well.
>>Ambar: See, I'm going to give
you the opportunity to read page 60
and annotate important information
that helps us better understand Jazmin
and her relationship
with her family. Okay?
>>Jennifer: So usually, what we
do is we use our prep periods.
Every week, I'll go to my
professional growth partner's room
for 15 minutes and then,
I'll take notes.
>>Ambar: It's all objective. You're
just writing down what you see,
that the students are saying and
doing, and what the educator is saying
and doing and you type
everything up in order to later
on provide the feedback with evidence.
>>Alexa: When I'm thinking about how
to pair teachers, I assign them based
on their learning needs,
strengths, and also personality.
Jennifer is really great
at setting up small groups.
That's a need Ambar may have
and then, I want Jennifer
to see how Ambar's annotating texts,
because that's something that'll
support her in her practice.
>>Ambar: So my annotations were that mom
was not very loving, but also, grandma--
>>Student: So the mom
followed the grandma.
>>Jennifer: So when I went
into Ms. Quinones' room,
I was looking to see the literacy
skills and how to apply them in math.
I noticed Ms. Quinones was
modeling annotations in math.
When we problem solve, we also need
to make annotation markings as well.
>>Ambar: So now, you guys are
going to have a chance to read it
on your own and continue annotating.
>>Ambar: So when I observe Ms.
Negron, in order to prepare to walk
into her classroom and get the
best out of the experience,
I make sure that I check
what we have spoken before.
Every week, then, we build on
the suggestions that we have.
>>Jennifer: So how is your triad doing?
>>Student: Good.
>>Jennifer: So you guys
solved the problem already?
>>Ambar: So after the 15-minute
observation every week, we sit down
and debrief using the TAG form.
>>Jennifer: TAG is-- the T stands
for tell something you like.
>>I noticed that you were
modeling how to annotate,
and I really liked how you
were, like, here's my evidence
in the text that supports this.
>>The A is to ask a question.
So maybe we didn't understand
what the kids were doing
or why a certain group
was given something.
So we ask a question for clarity.
>>Are the questions ever
differentiated for your small group?
>>Ambar: Some chapters have
front-loaded questions.
>>Jennifer: The G is to give a
suggestion. So what is one thing
that they can work on
that is attainable?
>>And that's actually great
that you said that because one
of my suggestions was
maybe you can give students
in your small group the question
ahead of time so that they can--
>>Ambar: Definitely, it's
very useful, the feedback.
At the end, you have
that concrete next step
of this is something that you can do.
We always e-mail the TAG form
because we want that person to have
that as a reference and
we CC Ms. Sorden.
>>Alexa: So it allows me to be a part of
the conversation, and it also allows me
to provide resources to help
them meet their next step.
It's about learning. It's
not about evaluation.
>>Jennifer: It's definitely
opened my eyes to things
that I don't necessarily see when I'm
in the classroom every day with kids
and it has helped me grow as a teacher.
We've created an environment
where we feel safe
with each other. It's
respectful feedback.
>>Ambar: It's part of our school
culture. So just by opening the doors
of their classroom, it's--
there's a bigger picture to this.
It's about how you could
improve teaching,
which would ultimately
help students learn.
>>Ambar: Bye.
>>Jennifer: Bye. Thank you.